this is the XO works industrial
exoskeleton and the point of it is to
let somebody who looks like me take
something that looks like this which is
a Milwaukee grinder hold it over their
head for a long time as though it didn't
weigh anything Ekso bionics grew out of
a defense funded project to make a load
carrying suit for military applications
for the company's best known for a
spin-off of power therapeutic
exoskeleton the people who are paralyzed
who've suffered strokes can use now the
companies going back to its roots in a
way with an exoskeleton built to make
difficult human jobs a lot easier EXO
isn't the only company getting into EXO
suits but they are one of the first to
build one a more construction workers
and Special Forces sure and it works
actually and now we see it five minutes
now we see why I went into journalism I
got to try out the suit at EXO's
Richmond California Factory it's
adjustable for people from five foot
four to six foot four weighs about 16
pounds and it feels a bit odd at first
if you could not twerk in this just
wouldn't I wouldn't recommend it let's
say the EXO industrial suits made for
heavy industry and construction it's
less Tony Stark's Iron Man armor and
more the power loader from aliens back
then they had the idea of vexes Galton
for industrial applications and the
interesting thing about that
as aliens was scheduled in the year 2020
so in our minds we got five years to get
to that but the exosuit is still pretty
far from Ripley's Alien Slayer this
thing is actually completely analog but
our industrial exoskeletons are our
first rounder products are actually
passive so there's no electronics
there's no batteries so there's nothing
to be plugged in which makes it pretty
exciting but then how do they fly and
shoot laser beams from there's no laser
beams there's no we don't have the arc
reactor yet like Tony Stark
no so what are those like the recent
opportunities I just have to say yeah
well we keep asking for but no one's
developed it yet totally different up is
now completely easy like I would stay
like that for hours
I can even have 240 pound grinder like a
sword since and the whole premise is
that we provide a parallel load path so
we have the tool there's a gravity
balancing arm that mounts to the chassis
and that chassis has a load path that
goes all the way to the ground so the
user inside doesn't feel any of the
weight the payload goes down through the
structure to the ground and they're just
there to maneuver and move the tool
around but there might be competition
soon Salt Lake City Sarcos is developing
a powered full bodysuit but what I want
to know is will it have a fencing
function I can fence for hours